[Music]
inclusion from a business perspective
isn't just about diversity diversity is
very very important
inclusion is also about creating a sense
of belonging of joint purpose of joint
creation of meaning and that we need
inclusion if you're a manager you need
inclusion in order to be able to find
out what's really happening at the edge
of the network and if you're presented
with a whole host of data you need
people who are different than your
surrounding you in order to be able to
detect which data is surprising and
which data I should then pay attention
to and whether that's all the way down
at the customer level or whether it's on
the warehouse level or whether it's on a
strategic leadership level the idea here
is that if everyone has a sense of
belonging they're going to advance the
mission of the organization
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host style and sake
on very excited to be talking about
radical inclusion and so much more we
have Ori Brafman joining us on the show
hello hey how are you thank you so much
for coming on I mean yes really
appreciate it you shoutouts Ryan
mazzaglia for introducing us thanks Mazz
yeah thanks Paz we much love much love
or his background is so epic
he's a multiple New York Times
bestselling author specializing in
organizational culture leadership change
accountability conflict resolution and
non-kinetic warfare propagating
non-violence and influencing society's
highest leaders and military government
NGOs and business it's the founder and
president of starfish leadership and
fully charged Institute teaching fellow
at UC Berkeley doing at the school of
business teaching improvisational
leadership and ethical artificial
intelligence also co-founder vegan org
which celebrates his 25th anniversary
this year in 2019 that is an epic
background or Wow and the links are
below
his most recent book radical inclusion
the links below to that such a fantastic
book loved reading it and prior to that
just so many other books all of the
links are below or he's Twitter and
LinkedIn as well are below or let's
start things off you know
the video there was so powerful and I'm
really excited to be getting into that
messaging more we live in a very
beautiful and complex world so I'm
curious what is your current take on the
state of humanity on the state of
humanity I would say a couple of
interesting things that are happening
the first is that it's getting
increasingly easier to organize without
centralized control and we're starting
to see the power of individuals to
express themselves to organize around a
similar cause and at the same time I
think communication is becoming much
more interfered with and by that I mean
as our communication goes down in
in in size whether it's a a text or a
five second video we make more
assumptions about the intentionality of
the other person of the messenger and
that in the assumption I think that we
start just communicating in in
ineffective ways so I think it's the
super interesting dilemma right right
and on the one hand it's it's a lot
easier to organize together and then the
other hand it's also a lot easier to
misunderstand one another
yeah and the this that that is such an
interesting dichotomy and on on one on
one side it's like holy cow we're gonna
be able to solve so many more of our
problems by having this decentralized
organizational it pushes towards solving
problems and then on the other hand it's
like how do we increase the bandwidth of
our ability to communicate thoughts to
each other how do we have more nuanced
and quantumness discourse amongst each
other where we look at each other in the
eyes and we care and we relate and then
we get towards that that global unity
yeah and that one sixty minute
conversation is very different than
sixty one-minute conversations yes and
how do we how do we at least acknowledge
that how do we get back to being able to
really understand each other yeah yeah
when when you were making that first
point I was thinking about how much as
we as we evolved we ended up
centralizing more and more agriculture
more more centralization occurred all
the way up to you know nation states now
and the way that we kind of behave with
these borders and and your citizen of a
specific country and rather than this
like global citizen and a little bit
more of like a trustful process and
things like that but it it it really
potentially speaks to what and you talk
about this a lot in starfish and the
spider but the the ability to
decentralize and what that means to our
our ability to to solve problems in a
grassroots style that doesn't require a
central authority
yeah yeah Ori how the hell did you end
up being a multiple time New York Times
bestselling author you born in Israel
went to Texas with family then to the
Bay Area where you spent the rest of
your life right yeah so I have a crazy
accident no one ever gets is where my
accidents from right it's this like
Israeli Texan salami all right the
Canadian is it so it's Hebrew Texan but
anything yes so tell us tell us about
this this a journey that you've had in
your life of like you know becoming a
multiple award winning author yeah tell
us about this so I business school in
2001 and I was actually on a plane with
a good friend of mine from Boston to San
Francisco and September 10th 2001 and
realized that the war the next day woke
up and obviously realized that the world
was a different place and wanted to do
something to make a difference and I
co-founded a network of CEOs working on
peace and economic development projects
around around the world and people are
like well who's in charge I was like not
me I was 26 and there what's the overall
strategy in the whole strategy was to
build to this this network and a couple
of the circles or ended up achieving
some remarkable results opened up the
borders between India and Pakistan
raised substantial amounts in my
planning projects in Africa they were
like how did you accomplish this and I
realized it wasn't me or us it was the
network it was the power of these very
distributed networks working on joint
causes and joint missions and started
looking at history and saw that there is
the same pattern that repeats itself
where people organized around shared
values and are able to change the world
in dramatic ways Alcoholics Anonymous
the anti-slavery movement the women's
suffrage movement and that they all
followed the same path and people have
to write a book and I'd never written
anything professionally before and these
were all header article strife
exactly yeah exactly exactly and one
thing led to another it was funny in
2006 or 2005 and we're talking to her
editor or publisher
what have you written and I was like
well I would talent show for the
business school may be started that's
right that's right
you looked look back like almost 400
episodes ago you know we were also very
much so like you know barely able to do
these really well and so that's how we
you know us how he gets started now okay
now how did that end up leading to your
interest in human psychology and writing
your first books so the first book was
starfish in the spider the metaphor of
that is it cut off the head of a spider
it dies it cut off the arm of a starfish
it was went back because unlike the
spider the starfish doesn't have a
central brain and from there I wrote a
couple books with my brother and my
older brother Rahm who is a psychologist
so I've been really interested about
both networks but also how people relate
to each other within these networks and
how you can improve the quality of
relationships within these distributed
networks ok so then as you're doing the
improving relationship between people in
the distributed networks and you're
seeing you're using this beautiful
analogy of cutting off the central brain
of the spider versus the regenerative
decentralized system of the starfish
what were some of these realizations for
you
you mean after the book came out mm-hmm
some of the big realizations were first
of all you can really really have an
impact on the energy levels of the
people that are around you and that you
can have an impact about other
energizing or draining the the people
who are closest to you that you work
with that you interact with how do you
change the energy of the organization
and the second thing that noticed over
the last year's is just how much these
starfish networks are changing the rules
of society so you see this in in
politics in technology and blockchain
how really there's an ability for people
to self-organize or to organize in a
distributed fashion and that it's
actually much more effective than
control so that you think that when you
give up control you lose power but in
fact you actually gain power the more
control you give up I'll be weird
tell that to the banks right well and at
the same time
how are banks gonna in are going to
react or to block - yeah and in work
right and and what are some of the
implications and are they gonna get more
disintermediated yeah yeah so correct a
couple a few years ago banks for like
well you know this this blockchain thing
you know and now there's serious
investment and then and people are
realizing that there really can be
something there yeah a lot of your work
seems to point in the direction of the
did the big difference between a
centralized controlling versus a this
radical inclusion decentralization and
then the meaning and purpose that arises
from that yeah so control is oftentimes
going to exclude
people and is going to try to submit how
people interact with one another what
people are going to focus on and
inclusion is essential for an open
society and that it turns out that you
actually need inclusion in order to get
better information and I think there as
more and more as well becomes complex
you're gonna depend on inclusion for
accuracy yes yes and you started yeah
hinting at that in the in in the first
video I want I want to see you know in
in the sorption spider I want I want you
to teach us about these kind of like
these crazy you start hinting at some of
the blockchain decentralization x' I
want people to know how exactly the
United States military credits you for
their foundation of being able to tackle
al-qaeda so my book was ended up in the
US Army and when you think about it
Teairra networks function a lot more
like starfish than they do like spiders
and the music's really simple imagine
taking on an opponent as formidable as
the United States you're not going to be
able to win a conventional war with I
against our army or navy or Air Force
and in order to adapt you basically are
gonna be as distributed as you can so in
order to fight these distributed
networks we actually need to be more
starfish like ourselves and what's
interesting is the harder that we fight
against a starfish
the stronger it becomes so you look at
the transition from al Qaeda and refile
Qaeda which bond on Isis and we take
down Isis and and now there's really a
lot of videos out there that are very
powerful and obviously concerning and
you you think about how do we so as a
country how do we take on the Nazi Party
right and so nine even in the nineteen
forties well we went to World War two
how do we take on Nazis today where are
they
isn't it interesting and very concerning
that it's become this decentralized and
that really you're starting to fight a
war where you're no longer able you know
I'm fighting a war for territory
you're fighting a war for time for
mindshare and how do you fight that war
it follows a very different set of rules
and we're moving away from wars with
bullets and more to the non-kinetic
sphere and by that I mean you're gonna
have to fight these narratives with
other alternative positive narratives
that support our open society
and we haven't fully tackled that yet
yeah this major difference between
between a there's a couple things here
one of the things as the is the the way
that a terror network can then act in a
decentralized way and that the the very
interesting aspect of being able to how
do you then combat it yourself as a
starfish yeah and then another thing is
this this um this transition to more on
a cyberwar front more on a deep fakes
front more on oh no what what is what is
what we do in the in the IT age now of
war rather than the bullet age of war
this is a big transition so where do
where do blockchain technologies in
crypto cryptography and things come into
play that that enable us to have a more
trust based social fabric these are very
pressing questions and that we need to
recognize we're not going to kill our
way out of this war we're gonna have to
turn to different tactics that are going
to be effective and a big part of that I
see more and more of a divide between
Washington DC and here in Silicon Valley
and beyond even just the political
divide there's a growing rift where
we're not talking as as a country about
security and we're not using the same
language oftentimes and that we're
oftentimes trying to solve this bridge
using policy and you know
people are lamenting this fact but I
think that what we're actually
experiencing is this is a human problem
and we're not yet dealing with it in a
human way so you think about for a
moment what is it a week ago Australia
passed they the law about if if a if a
provider has videos that are harmful if
they don't take the get taken down in a
in a reasonable amount of period
whatever that means then there's a huge
fine and jail time is this trying to cut
the head these are all trying to cut
right right as opposed to saying you
know these platforms where a lot of
these networks live on really need to
take more seriously about how do we
change the tenor of the conversation how
do we change the how do we avoid
violence how do we make these nonviolent
interactions and that we need to start
taking it seriously as opposed to
shouting at each other which i think is
all too easy these days you you consult
for every Department of the military for
every yeah now my question then would be
you spoke a moment ago about this
disconnect between DC and Silicon Valley
also this kind of disconnect globally
between the cutting off the head of the
spider versus the decentralized starfish
so I'm curious to hear your thoughts on
this does it does it does it feel like
like what is the role that Palantir in
their data fusion technology plays in
government providing safety security for
the country will role does Twitter and
YouTube being able to chop the head off
the different content creators that are
saying things that disagrees with their
community
Guidelines versus how do we take tackle
that in a dissent in the decentralized
method so a way of tackling this in a in
a more distributed fashion is first
recognizing a couple of things one is we
can keep on chopping the heads off and
they'll just become more and more
distributed and they'll go darker and
darker onto the web and instead what if
we focus on amplifying voices of
Tolerance yeah of open society yes and
it really is a search engine issue right
or what are the top ten so we know
politically that you gain power by
having the most compelling narrative
yeah yeah Chris right that story right
yeah and you talk to him whatever you
were going to search on your top ten
results are going to be viewed and much
dramatically so how do you help amplify
these voices that do exist that are
talking about tolerance for talking
about inclusion or talking about
different ways of interacting so rather
than thinking about going around and
it's even about metaphor right chopping
off heads how do we amplify what already
exists but in an effective in an
effective way and that we're reluctant
because it's interesting both the
government and I think tech is so afraid
of the narrative right you control the
narrative you how do we think about
narrative in a different way of saying
you know what for narrative to really
drive you you you need inclusion you
need people to be to have a sense of
belonging to it and how do you then
effectively as leaders amplified the
narratives that are helping Society okay
here would be a follow up question then
as we're entering into the the insane
attention economy and the gold rush for
people's attention that we're how much
effort is are we distributing it should
we should we aim to distribute effort
evenly amongst our radical inclusion
from from a community and a corporate
perspective in on a grassroots style of
development towards this tolerance
making that mean spread means of
tolerance equanimity peace dignity
kindness towards each other in our
nuanced conversations about figuring out
the best code moving forward that that
is that that grassroots side and then
the other side is this like kind of like
government code like how much do we
focus on that on the code of governance
as well so there's a couple of big
issues one is how do we interact with
one another and oftentimes the content
is going to be dependent on the media so
the the reason that we grew up on four
minutes songs because that's the length
of a of over 45 right and the reason
that songs are 2 minutes today is
because the that that's a the length of
an Instagram video so that by allowing
people to by not splicing the
conversation into a million pieces
that's really step number one and and an
essential step how do we effectively
talk to each other the second one is
specifically to your point how do we
think about the best ideas are going to
come from the edge of the network and as
a leader
your role is transforming from
governance and control
to amplify the ideas that are the most
resonant and have the most power and the
thing is that you don't know where the
best idea is gonna come from you just
don't know you need to have a very wide
network of a lot of nodes being able to
have a sense of participation and then
the leader then can then shine a light
on those nodes that have the most
compelling and beneficial and then what
would be a strong mechanism for a leader
shining the light on the best most
tolerant most nuanced most progressing
conversations well da what would be a
mechanism are we talking about
yeah it's that's a good question you
just have to repeat it you just have to
amplify it it would just be like a
fundamental code of over Twitter or
YouTube of propagating and I've started
thinking about videos as living
organisms yes and all living organisms
are living organisms that we know abide
by two rules to survive they need to eat
and they need to reproduce the way that
a video eat is views right
the way that reproduces through shares
to shares and derivative content yes so
that so one when we started the this
this video with with content from before
and and now we're expanding upon it
which which then helped the original
video we produce so we're doing that as
we speak to its reproduction when
there's even a three-minute chunk of
this video being shared right its
production and we need to think of
videos literally as as organisms and
thereby that those simple it's their
very simple economic rules
yeah and channels or content creators as
organisms as well that are that are
launched the feeding organism the
feeding the reading we are feeding the
video so right now if this is at all a
compelling video then we're feeding the
videos and eventually who the host
companies monetize by having more views
right and then after after a while you
can only have so many views right if
your video gets a couple billion times
eventually they need the derivative
content and then that gets really really
how in how in a in a in a in a in a in a
Pareto distribution where it it it seems
as though now with such it's such such
there's such amount of difficulty maybe
even like two or three years of building
up a Twitter account or a YouTube
channel or whatever maybe before getting
even that bit of traction that that that
verses the verses of the memes share
let's say the mimetic share of larger
already existing platforms how do we get
the ideas of tolerance that may only
have hundreds of views into the into the
millions or billions of view
we just start by taking it seriously
and we need to recognize that if we're
fighting it so we've moved away from a
battle of ideas to a battle of
narratives ideas are either right or
wrong so I can debate you about whether
well there's not much today but climate
change you can debate that and the
scientific community has come to a
conclusion
yes and find yourself more on open
borders or closed borders exactly sir
narratives are about is it interesting
or is it born yeah this is a cool point
okay teach us more so and that would be
the only so a meme or video or
information gets shared if it's
interesting and compelling and how do
you take something that you might be
very right on yes we should have a more
tolerant open society but how do we make
that conversation into it make it
compelling telling enough to get shared
to get shared yeah so when I was when I
was in college I I was involved with my
freshman year with the animal rights
group I'd UC Berkeley and I joined there
were like eight members and they were
like holding closest size and and wasn't
very effective and my second semester my
freshman year they were like hey do you
want to be president of this
organization was like okay and my first
act was to kill the name of the
organization it was Berkeley students
for Animal Liberation and they had all
these people from the animal rights
community call me and said like why
you're killing and I was like because
this is not ever going to work and
instead
co-founded vegan org and vegan actually
and we said you know what rather than
fighting about whether going vegan is
right or wrong I bet you I can make it
fun and interesting so the first project
was getting the UC Berkeley dorms to
offer vegan meals yes and after that we
decided hey you know this vegan meals
like that but share more Valerie and we
had a campaign call that make vegan you
know billions and billions saved their
God so for some reason McDonald's saw
the the logo and wasn't that amused and
they they threatened to sue us and at
the time I was I was 19 and were like
sure go ahead
I had a bike and we said you know
McDonald's and fast food restaurants
have used playgrounds and clowns to sell
junk food to kids we can also use the
same imagery to teach people about
eating well and eating a diet that been
good for the planet and McDonald's
withdrew their their lawsuit yeah and 25
years later
McDonald's is now introducing the
McGuigan burger an actual McVie they're
actually introducing vegan burger oh my
goodness
it's it's finally come right Wow and
then into the Binta president of
McDonald's also be take a chair man
position at of V I'd beyond
yeah at it beyond beyond beat Wow
so you're seeing that again McDonald's
is is is a company based on economics
and you they're going to react to the
market it based on the narrative yeah
not necessarily I don't think they're
waking up in
in saying like I'm determined to sell as
much beef as I can they're they're
determined to sell as many hamburgers as
the Canon and it and if we can change
the narrative and if you can take on
that narrative battle and recognizing
again are you boring or you're
interesting are you is your narrative
gonna have positive or negative energy
is it going to be energizing or draining
then you can actually stop win the
battle this is a very good story for how
to spread memes that's why you bring
this up at this time because you spread
memes in a way that is pushing us
towards a more sustainable cycle of food
consumption and and I'm planetary
trajectory and so this is this is maybe
one of the answers to what we were
discussing a little bit ago which is
this is how to spread a meme of
tolerance compassion of positive
civilizational trajectory and you did it
in a grassroots way and that's it that's
like this is a good way for other people
young people to really think about oh
this could be a strategy for me to try
and and make and make change right so if
you get really really specific so what
is going to be compelling for people to
watch and we know that unfortunately
violence is going to be compelling for
people to watch right there's such a
fear instinct right there's there's
fearful stuff there's entertainment ism
and there's also funny stuff so that if
you can a little funny I think you're
talking about this pretty serious issue
of animal consumption and you can say
the cotan is actually fun and I can win
a war about whether or not something is
fun and hip and cool yeah because it's
all the cool kids are doing it and I
think that it's it's tempting and
sometimes dangerous right to the easy
way of getting something shared is
to be as provocative and kind of in in
trench as much fear as possible and
there's an another even more effective
way of I think eventually non-violence
does win yeah right yeah yeah yeah a lot
for further decisions yes yes yes lifer
marine decisions you you explain this
really powerful way of combining the
memes of a positive civilizational
trajectory with something that is that
is interesting captivating entertaining
and and I think that those two things
together have a strong ability to
catalyze change now we talked about this
a little bit earlier I want to I want to
talk about this this this feeling of
belonging this feeling of meaning and
purpose and I love how you explain it on
an on an edge we talk a lot about the
edge of knowledge on the show and how we
sit down with different leaders at
different edges of knowledge different
vertices and we aim to disseminate that
to the public in ways that are fun and
relatable entertaining exciting
inspirational and so when you speak at
Amazon's headquarters your schooling and
speaking and what you write about in the
book you make it very clear that people
with a greater sense of being included
of participation in what is happening
with the with with with the organization
that they're a part of wil will feel
greater amounts of meaning purpose
actualization and there will be better
communication from that edge to to to
the organization's objectives and goals
so I'm tell you a story about in in
hospitals one of the
killers that hospitals face aren't just
trauma and diseases there are antibiotic
resistant staph infection and best way
of picking up a MRSA is by going to the
hospital because if someone has it then
it gets transmitted and there's a really
easy there's a really straightforward
way of combating Marissa you wash your
hat and we've known that since the
eighteen hundreds right marsh and so
hospitals across the country have done
different campaigns where they put up
signs above sinks and said wash your
hands didn't work so they put up
colorful science please wash your hands
didn't work
so they took doctors actual doctors to
to train them on washing hands I wash
your hands didn't work
that's because information does not
change behavior information does not
change behavior if it did no one would
smoke everyone floss and instead of
hitting people with more and more
information and one more control about
washing hands this nonprofit I was in
the board of we assembled a group of
everyone from the head of infection
control to the janitor and we just said
hey you know how do we deal with this
with this problem and the janitor said
you know I I made an observation that in
this one wing where there's a lot of
infection the garbage cans are empty
people aren't using gloves and we're
like well that's weird but there's a
mode which which is nothing about me
without me there isn't we can't talk
about them so the group gets up and goes
to the wing and said hey you guys heard
you should really be wearing gloves why
are you wearing gloves and said well the
nurses in the specific wing have very
small hands
and this hospital so cheap they don't
get enough excess said what what to give
you more gloves than of course would
wear them would use them so the janitor
bust out a pen parts down his number
every time that wing ran out of extra
small gloves that come up and he
replacement in a few minutes and small
incremental changes like that that
reduced the levels of infection in the
hospital by 70 percent in one year Wow
now it's not to say that every wing in
the hospital needed extra small gloves
nor is it to say that the janitor should
be made the head of infection control
yeah but it's depending on the context
of the situation think about people who
show up at work and I doubt that people
want to show up what most people want to
show up at work and one to make
difficulties or make someone's day
horrible like I think most people show
up like why don't you contribute how do
you harness that energy and how do you
create a sense of belonging where people
can have a voice but then can can see
how their voice actually is making a
difference how do you create that level
of participation yeah and who would have
thought that the solution would be as
simple as having the nursing staff
communicate to the custodians right and
then it's it's and it's it's dozens of
solutions like that yeah right so it's
not just one solution but yes and the
janitor has better information yeah but
whether people are using gloves yes then
these information campaigns hospitals
using this mini goes but I'm not gonna
know poor room unless I get it now so
it's like the president of the hospital
and all of the staff at the top they're
not at the edge like the custodian eggs
eggs exactly and the custodians looking
in the basket every single day and the
amount of and so if there's a way to get
the data yeah the information the
knowledge that the custodian nose to the
to the organization in a way that can
actually make the change how can we find
this information and how can we apply it
into the organization exactly how can we
get the custodian to be a part of that
narrative of hey we're actually trying
to help people and we're trying to
prevent disease and we're all a part of
that mission so this isn't how do you
create that sense of belonging and this
is where we really need to decouple
inclusion and diversity they're both
very important diversity is in all the
marketing departments it's diversity and
inclusion inclusion right diversity is a
payroll issue so who is on your payroll
and whose inclusion is a cultural issue
are you going to feel comfortable
speaking up is your voice going to be
heard do you feel a sense of belonging
in the organization
yeah this decoupling is very interesting
I I see it now I see the decoupling of
something that's big that's become so
important to identify and and when and
when you do give people a feeling of
belonging where their voice makes impact
then they feel more comfortable speaking
up the data from the edges gets
distributed to the right locations more
effectively and more positive change
gets catalyzed right and now let's try
to synthesize some of this with the
conversation about networks so whether
I'm trying to fight terror networks or
have good ideas for how society can
people can have better interactions with
one another those ideas I don't claim to
have that is those the right ideas those
ideas are distributed across the world
how do you create a network that is
broad enough and that that gives people
a chance to participate that they can
then have a true voice and actually be
able to solve some of these very complex
issues and that different voices of
chimey depending on the context of the
problem
this leads me into asking you about the
these the geopolitical side of inclusion
that that there see there's seems to be
now with more and more of the
exponential technology effect on society
we have the benefits of being able to
wear a fully immersive experience into
what it would be like to get behind
someone's eyes we can gain a lot of
empathy from that at the same time in
the amount of Technology with some
aspects of synthetic biology or
malevolence and artificial intelligence
or what what have you yeah so there's
this this yeah there's technology being
a double-edged sword in that sense so
how do we extend the inclusion this
inclusive fitness
out to all of earth to this feeling of
unity with evolution that we got here
together I think
we need to take a side
you can't both be from an abling
authoritarianism while also enabling
civil open society and the two will
eventually clashing like China so can a
company have different rules if the
operating in a more authoritative
country than and or should they be more
values based but saying you know what
regardless of the government we need to
abide by open society and by non
authoritarian non authoritarianism and
that try to have it both ways the
challenges that technology can and has
been used as a very authoritarian tool
yeah and that unless we're very
conscious and unless we we take the
values based approach of openness of
equality then I think we can open some
very dark doors and I think from a new
political perspective we're recognizing
that we can't really go at it alone
it's it's not gonna be effective but
rather than sowing discord and you think
about it just think about how much
discord is sown every day just people
just being afraid of each other
so much fear how do we move away from
this place of being afraid of each other
as humans or two countries correct to a
place of recognizing that we might be
working towards similar goals and how do
yeah how do we come together as as so
many forces are trying to split us apart
yeah Jeanne aqua C of course we're doing
a little research last night on on the
the potential forms of governance based
on problem-solving creative intelligence
love and compassion and I thought that
could be a potential just interesting
thought experiment to run and see what
that would be like obviously yeah well I
I think that blockchain and I think
would just discover we're just figuring
out the real implications of blockchain
that blockchain might have what are
called micro ubiquity so that if I
decide to have almost an island here in
San Francisco where I can essentially
have a community of people where all
transactions are going to be unblocked
chain and if the community is isn't
entirely open to anyone but is only
essentially open to people that I trust
in the real world am I going to be able
to live in an island and as the state of
politics and the National Dialogue
becomes more and more shrill will people
start living in these little digital
islands and what does that look like
right and are you going to
disintermediate government
it was really interesting hearing you
say that radical inclusion can't live
simultaneously with an authoritarian the
state yeah two things just don't they'll
eventually class yeah yeah yeah people
do people really feel meaning purpose
participation in an authoritative
authoritarian state and authoritarian
states end up in the outcome is always
the same eventually people rise up and
demand to have freedom in to and to have
a voice but we've seen the pattern
repeats itself over and over and over
again or it feels like another part of
what this this conversation slowly kind
of edging towards as well is that that
part part of what happened with this
extremely quick exponential technology
age in the last couple decades is that
we've seen a heavy amount of wealth
concentration occur in in just a couple
handfuls of people and that this has
created a massive destabilization in
civilization and so potentially what
some of the decentralization
technologies and radical inclusion
mentalities do is that they they you you
take these this viral video now of these
you know billionaires multi millionaires
dumping fifty thousand bucks on their
head and this is kind of the mentality
now is that you know they're like we
didn't need this tax cut we need this
50k to go to other people artists and
entrepreneurs young people that want to
build that don't have the financial
stability they're still trying to stay
afloat so that
I think in this country and also around
the world but let's talk about
specifically in this country as the the
divide becomes bigger and bigger and
bigger we need to remind ourselves why
is it that people even with different
economic classes why aren't people
rebelling and I think that the reason
for that is that people think that they
that they too can succeed in if they
play by the rules and if if they work
hard and it's interesting you look at a
bunch of opinions a very broad brush but
a bunch of folks who are staunchly
against the estate tax but there it
doesn't actually apply to them but
they're like there you can give up well
if I were a millionaire then I don't
want the estate tax up when you take
that away the idea that if you work hard
enough and that you play by the rules
when you start having the system that's
gained that's a thing when you're gonna
start having massive massive social
unrest and I think we're tittering on
that we're seeing that with the I've
been following the admission scandal and
you're saying like it's not fair it's
just why is it bad
you can just write a check and have your
kid go to school and taking someone
else's spot and that the moment that
that decays is the moment I think that
people get really really really upset in
ways that we haven't seen when they feel
that the system is rigged when the
corruption becomes that transparent yeah
yeah
yeah cuz I'm the hard-working that you
were describing that people feel like oh
I can work hard and I can achieve good
for myself my family my community etc
but then they work hard and they see
corruption actually
and they lost right yeah and I think for
for a long time in the United States we
had that really going for ourselves
right you consider you know and it was
all a democracy right and there's
obviously been issues of sexism and
racism and let's be clear the the game
is never the decks have never been
stacked evenly but there's been enough
of a sense of that you yes you can
actually achieve by by playing with the
rules and once you take that away yeah
yeah which then leads again back to the
inclusion of that people feel that they
they need a voice and and they need to
to belong to a game that's that's a fair
game I'm fairly certain now that after
you know talking to you more feels like
you know maybe even 90 plus percent of
me feels like we're going towards a very
decentralized distributed header our key
in many ways of a civil society where
where we don't no longer depend on such
a massive ego we don't get so we stay a
little more humble we understand that
the creative potential of artificial
intelligence is greater than that of of
humanity in some ways and that that kind
of potentially might be this next
progressional shift yes but what's
really interesting is that we've
arguably come to an age or relatively
everyone has a voice of right it's very
easy to broadcast and now we need to ask
ourselves a question of ok how do we
broadcast it what kind of messages do we
actually want to podcast and how do we
effectively amplify
more meaning and signal truth meaning
yeah yeah yeah how do we amplify such a
such a crucial question yeah I hope I
hope there's both parties partake I hope
that more on the on the top down on the
tech tech corporate side of things in
the political government side of things
aim to bubble up meaning truth and
signal meanwhile the grassroots aims to
really propagate those memes as well and
we need to be very clear that there is a
war going on of people either sowing
fear and discord and and we're becoming
more stressed out and more fearful of
each other and we need to recognize that
that is an actual ongoing tactics and
that the only way to overcome that is by
stopping by by not being afraid and by
seeking harmony where we can by seeking
non-violence where we can that is the
only counter to the only possibility is
right there is no way to peace peace is
the way peace is the way yeah yeah
seeking harmony and non-violence Ori
what does it mean to be fully charged
the fully charges to so this is in
Washington I said in Washington DC with
my business partner is Tom Rath who came
out of Gallup and wrote the streams
finder took my notebooks and
we've looked a lot about human
interactions and that any interaction
can either be energizing or draining and
you could ask yourself so rather than
saying to people hey you're you're a
jerk or they say this is stuff I'm a my
energized by this interaction or am i
drained and it turns out that we're all
in a network and that if we drain one
one draining interaction it takes for
energetic factions to count count or
contrasting from a psychological
perspective and you start thinking and
reading inner yeah and interestingly the
way to be energizing is to actually work
on energizing yourself first yeah and
it's with the cycle of sleep what we eat
and how we move yeah what stimuli we
take in yeah and having meaningful
interactions so we work with
organizations and how do you how do you
energize the people around you love it
love it and if you just think about that
right everyone probably wants to have to
be a positive energizing force like who
wants to be draining yeah yeah and we
want to spread that butterfly effect
around the world yes yes okay now Ronnie
we're gonna do the end questions know
what thought conversation fine I just I
just want to acknowledge there are some
people like to be miserable they like to
inflict pain and we can't we can't you
know dismiss them what you say what what
kind of person doesn't want to be a
positive influence doesn't want to be
draining there's lots of people among us
that to just to do like that
[Laughter]
I want to ask a question on behalf of
Ron and I together is there is there
some sort of a force beyond the 3d
reality that is at play on the planet
that is beyond my that is beyond my
knowledge I do think that we're
recognizing that there's a lot more to
the world that we don't understand
whether on the quantum level or and I
think that very very very simple level
there's really only two forces I think
that exist that I know of there's fear
in those love you're running towards
everybody away yeah yeah yeah
and there and there may be forces at
play on that are aiming to propagate
those two yeah yeah yeah yeah
so all right let's let's let's do let's
do our simulation questions all right
first question is are we alone in the
cosmos I think that would be arrogant to
assume that we're alone
so I would say no we're not alone but I
was a Peace Studies major from UC
Berkeley so my my sense is that we're
not alone we're gonna call you but it
just it would just be it would be too
presumptuous we're gonna call you up
when we make the inter stellar slide
right conference yeah um next question
is the simulation so we will ask you are
we in a simulation
I think there's another question which
is if you wanna simulation so if we're
in the in the matrix
do you take the whatever color pill red
or blue yeah right do you leave the
simulation and I would my question is
that we I think we're going to figure
this out in our lifetimes I do think
that
that we yeah I I don't think I don't
know would you stay in it or would you
leave if and if the if the is so the
matrix would you would you leave over
this day I think you made a really
interesting point which is that we can
poke with the scientific probe at at the
simulation to see write and understand
ourselves in eventually in it and then
yeah and then can you leave how can you
leave can you make another one keep
embedding these within each other all
these yeah all these questions and that
the world is interesting enough where we
have a couple of mins about whatever you
say about the world we have this myth of
centralization of command control we
also have this myth of scarcity yeah and
you're starting to see experiments like
Burning Man saying you know what if what
if you don't make that assumption of of
greed and but some of the people here on
on Market Street do have real scarcity
happening to them still well it's like
very strange that we have this burning
man and like yeah and then we have this
like you know Market Street San
Francisco right mid market area like
yeah I mean and yeah you can't tell
people living in a concrete housing
project to save the planet right and so
yes we have a lot of social fabric to
commend and we've yeah together first I
uplifts people because it's a roll of
the dice if you're born into two parents
have no love and compassion addicted to
drugs or if you're born to the middle
class or higher class wherever around
the world we're doing an abysmal job
the divide yeah uplifting yeah faster
not actively yeah last question on a
shore what is the most beautiful thing
in the world
true love
tell us more
recognising that word loved bye-bye
there's so many people around us and
that love is just an attractive force
and who knows necessarily rational
reason or but that you can make it a
sort of contact with someone saying like
I'm going to put your needs on the level
of my needs or above my needs and that
if we do a little bit of that just the
level of beauty and the level of
compassion that we can have I think you
change the world that's right yeah so
beautifully said thank you so much Orie
thanks for coming on to our show thank
you this what you miss about all of your
work yeah we're huge fans and we're
excited to continue propagating your
memes out into the world
keep co-creating thank you so much for
coming on thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let us know what you're thinking about
this episode about radical inclusion
about decentralization of our best these
best strategies to get to a state of
unity and a state of meaning and purpose
for all beings check out aures links
below check it has a website link below
check out the Twitter check out the
LinkedIn check out the book go and buy
the book take it of a read share it with
your communities very very important to
do so huge shout out to Ron Vargas our
producer and director thank you very
much we greatly appreciate you and
support the artisan entrepreneurs that
you believe in support them help them
grow help them they're mean spread into
the world help simulation our links are
below we need your help in growing as
well and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world huge thank you for tuning in and
we will see you soon much love
[Music]
[Music]